une procession en signe de contestation
le vert pour la nature le bleu pour
l'eau haut en couleurs les membres de
l'association extinction rébellion ont
marché dans les rues du comté de
cornouaille avec plusieurs pancartes aux
slogans explicites effondrement de la
biodiversité changement climatique noyé
dans les promesses
les activistes n'ont pas manqué de faire
preuve d'ingéniosité dans leurs actions
coup de poing
[Musique]
l'action du titanic est une métaphore de
ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés ou les
ingénieurs de l'époque ont été ignorés
les scientifiques sont toujours ignoré
les politiciens nous certes un affreux
discours vert il y a eu beaucoup de
rires et de félicitations de tapes dans
le dos ou deux coups de coude mais en
fait les gaz à effet de serre continuent
d'augmenter
les différents mouvements sociaux
écologistes à l'air notamment sur la
déforestation de la forêt amazonienne et
appelle à plus de responsabilité et
d'actions de la part des pays les plus
riches
crise écologique économique sanitaire
pour l'organisation caritative oxfam la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins doit
devenir une priorité pour les pays les
plus industrialisés en ligne de mire les
bénéfices engrangés par les entreprises
pharmaceutiques
nous avons créé neuf nouveaux
milliardaires du vaccin au cours des six
derniers mois
donc il ne s'agit pas de faire de
l'argent excessif mais de permettre aux
marchés de se développer et à d'autres
fabricants du monde entier de fabriquer
ces vaccins et de sauver des vies le
président américain qui a promis ainsi à
son arrivée en grande bretagne des
distribués dans les prochains mois 500
millions de doses du vaccin fighter à
plus de 90 pays
réduire les inégalités dans le domaine
de la santé du travail
les activistes mobiliser également pour
une égalité des sexes
nous savons que très peu de femmes sont
dans et autour des politiques et des
prises de décisions sur ce qui est
nécessaire
nous appelons à l'action pour lutter
contre la violence à l'égard des femmes
et soutenir les organisations de femmes
à être dans les prises de décisions de
façon critique
une grande partie de ses militants
souhaitent la création d'assemblées de
citoyens afin de répondre aux
problématiques du futur